MARK MIRCHANDANI: Building
your infrastructure
or hosting your application
in the Cloud can be tricky.
One misconfiguration
and your costs
could quietly creep
up or even skyrocket.
Your performance
could slow to a crawl,
or you could have holes in
your security big enough
to cause some serious trouble.
It can be difficult to
stay on top of things,
but you don't have
to do it alone.
Today, I'm going to tell
you about Active Assist,
the intelligence baked
into Google Cloud that
helps you troubleshoot,
configure, and optimize
your infrastructure with ease.
So what is Active Assist?
Well, it's not just one thing.
It's a portfolio of
tools and services
that span across Google Cloud.
Active Assist combines data,
intelligence, and machine
learning to provide you with
an array of tools specifically
tuned to your usage.
These tools are
designed to reduce
the complexity of managing
infrastructure in the Cloud.
The Active Assist
portfolio includes
the recommendation
hub, and an API,
as well as a collection
of Recommenders.
Let's break down
what Recommenders are
and how they work.
Recommenders offer personalized
intelligent insights
and recommendations for
various Google Cloud resources
and services based
on your usage data.
These recommendations
expose opportunities
to fine-tune and optimize your
configuration in various areas.
For example, if you run virtual
machines on Compute Engine,
you can reduce costs by
shutting down or deleting
any virtual machines that
aren't actively being used.
The Idle VM Recommender will
let when a virtual machine
is idle or unused.
Recommendations are made on
based on Cloud monitoring data
and are continuously
being updated.
Another example is
enforcing the best practice
of least privilege.
This includes making
sure that users only
have the permissions that
they actually need and use.
The IAM Recommender will spot
any excess permissions granted
to any accounts and
offer alternative roles
and permissions
to grant instead.
To view or manage
recommendations,
users will require the
appropriate IAM roles
corresponding to the
type of Recommender
that they need access to.
These permissions are also
bundled in some roles,
like the Owner role.
That way, you can delegate
the visibility and management
of recommendations to
different users or teams.
Once you have access
to recommendations,
there's a number of ways that
you can view and manage them.
First, you might
see them in context
on the pages for the services
that they correspond to.
For example, you'll see
IAM policy recommendations
at the top of the
IAM and Admin page
and next to any accounts that
might have excess permissions.
In the same way, the Compute
Engine VM Instances page
will tell you when there are
machine type recommendations,
at the top of the page
and next to any machines
that the recommendations
apply to.
This visibility ensures
that administrators
for these services
don't miss any
of the latest recommendations
that could positively
impact the organization.
Recommenders can also be
accessed from the Cloud Console
via the recommendation hub,
where you can view, dismiss,
or apply recommendations
with just a few clicks.
In the recommendation
hub, each Recommender
will display with a card
with its description
and a summary of
the recommendations
that it's generated, along with
the impact of actually applying
those changes.
You can click View All
for any Recommender
to see more details about the
individual recommendation.
Recommendations can
also be accessed
from the gcloud
command line interface
for more advanced and
programmatic management.
Accessing recommendations
through the CLI
reveals additional
information and properties,
such as priority and
primary impact category.
These properties are helpful
in identifying recommendations
that could have the biggest
effect on costs, performance,
and security.
By familiarizing
yourself with some
of the features
of Active Assist,
you can reduce the complexity
of running the cloud.
A great place to
start is getting
to know all the different
Recommenders that Active
Assist has to offer.
Collectively, Recommenders
will equip you
to do six things successfully--
manage your costs wisely,
maximize the performance
of your systems, mitigate your
security risk proactively,
deliver high availability and
reliable services to your end
users, spend less time managing
your cloud configuration,
and reducing the carbon
footprint of your workloads.
In the next few videos, we're
going to focus primarily
on three areas--
costs, performance,
and security.
Then we'll take a look at how
we can manage recommendations
across multiple projects inside
of a single organization.
Stay tuned for the
next video, where
we start by taking a
look at what Recommenders
can do for cost optimization.
See you there.